one of my favorite quotes it comes from
William Gibson and it says the futures
already here it's just not evenly
distributed and so a lot of what we are
seeing in China right now could be
coming to a theater near us real soon
and I agree that the US government would
have a hard time implementing all of
that but you know Facebook is
implementing a lot of it without it
being policy we're just willingly giving
them all of our data because it's a
quote unquote free service and when
Apple and Google suddenly say they're
gonna work together for geolocation and
contact tracing because without it we
can't restart our economy and I think
there are a lot of Americans who would
be very willing to say well I want
control of my data but if that's the
only way I can get back to work I think
a lot of people gonna take that you know
my mom well you know me I grew up in the
projects my mom was not a capitalist
because she didn't have capital she
would have been a capitalist if she had
capital but she didn't believe in that
system because her view was with you
know capitalist are just people that try
to screw me and my family for their own
benefit and so this idea that somehow
Americans would never tolerate X Y or Z
I think starts to change when Americans
get pissed off that their system isn't
providing for them Americans would never
vote for a socialist president except a
lot of Americans now are smore
supportive of things that feel like
socialism in the United States because
they think capitalism doesn't work for
them so I think representative democracy
and capitalism as we have lived it in
the last 40 years you're in my lifetime
Andrew do not appear to be working for
the majority of the American population
and that that I think will lead us to
change what we are and are not prepared
to tolerate from our leaders you mean my
quote unquote socialist ideas like
giving everyone 1,200 bucks for example
I mean I've heard of that as an idea
right yeah yeah there was someone who
ran around the country talking about
that a lot